Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonjour,
je m’appelle Cécile,
je suis médecin et un peu geek.
On m’a demandé de venir vous parler
de la révolution des nouvelles
technologies en santé.
Alors, je vais vous embarquer
dans une histoire de tech.
Mais comme derrière toute technologie,
il y a de l’humain,
eh bien, l’humain y tiendra
une belle place également.
Qui, dans cette salle,
a déjà entendu des histoires
de personnes choquées
par un médecin qui aura annoncé
un diagnostic grave de façon brutale,
peu empathique, avec des mots
beaucoup trop scientifiques,
dans un couloir d’hôpital
ou entre deux portes ?
Beaucoup d’entre nous, n’est-ce pas ?
Et alors, pensez-vous que remplacer
ce médecin par un ordinateur
pour cette même annonce
serait une avancée ?
Avant de répondre à la question,
remontons un peu le temps en arrière.
Quand j’étais jeune étudiante,
c’était le début de ce qu’on appelait
la santé connectée.
C’était l’époque des premiers forums
en ligne comme Doctissimo,
où vous pouviez lire que
si vous aviez mal au bras droit,
c’était probablement
un cancer de la cheville gauche,
des premiers objets connectés,
comme les montres connectées,
plus ou moins fiables,
si vous voyez ce que je veux dire.
Et on commençait tout juste à parler
de big data et d’algorithmes
qui, un jour, nous remplaceraient,
nous médecins.
En somme, c’était la Silicon Valley
qui arrivait en France
pour le meilleur et pour le pire.
Pour moi, c’était une révolution,
ça allait changer la donne en médecine.
Mais ce que j’entendais autour de moi,
de la part de mes collègues,
c’était plutôt :
«C’est complètement débile et inutile,
ces nouveaux gadgets.»
«Internet ? Ah non, c’est le diable.
Il ne faut surtout pas
que les patients y aillent.
Et puis, je n’ai pas fait 10 ans d’études
pour être remplacé
par un algorithme, quand même.»
Alors, comment vous dire que moi, à côté,
je passais un peu pour l’ovni
qui sortait du droit chemin ?
Pour moi, ce que j’y voyais,
c’était une techno débutante
et immature, certes.
Mais c’est le concept qui était inédit.
Ce concept de pouvoir partager
la connaissance entre tous.
Ce concept de pouvoir construire
de nouveaux outils pour les soignants
et pour les patients.
Il fallait juste s’atteler à construire
de meilleurs outils tous ensemble.
Ben oui, tous ensemble.
C’est un peu ça, le problème.
C’est qu’il fallait surmonter cette chose
et faire se rencontrer le monde
de la tech et celui de la médecine.
Et ce n’était pas gagné.
Parce que sans les soignants
et les patients,
eh bien, on ne pouvait pas
construire de bons outils,
parce que les entrepreneurs qui,
entre vous et moi, sont souvent jeunes
et n’ont connu que le rhume
et la varicelle,
ils avaient plein d’idées,
ce n’est pas le problème.
Mais ça manquait quand même
de pertinence une fois sur le terrain.
Une fois, j’ai vu une start-up qui avait
créé une coupe menstruelle connectée
avec une batterie et une antenne Bluetooth
à l’intérieur de la coupe.
Grâce à une appli, les femmes pouvaient
suivre l’abondance de leurs règles,
en millilitres.
Elles pouvaient voir la couleur
du sang sur leur smartphone -
non, non, je ne rigole pas -
et voir où elles en étaient
dans leur cycle menstruel,
au cas où elles n’auraient pas remarqué
qu’effectivement,
elles avaient bien leurs règles.
Bien sûr, quand la coupe est pleine,
vous recevez une notification.
Et ils ont quand même réussi
à lever 160 000 dollars.
Ben moi, je trouve ça assez flippant.
Et comme si les soignants n’étaient pas
déjà trop frileux sur le sujet,
les médias n’ont pas aidé,
à coup de gros titres sensationnels
déclarant la guerre entre le médecin
et la tech, entre l’homme et la machine.
Et bien sûr, ce n’est pas le médecin,
ce vieux dinosaure,
qui allait en ressortir vainqueur.
OK, c’est vrai, la technologie
est un petit miracle.
Un grand, même, OK.
Que ce soient les biotechnologies qui ont
permis de créer de nouveaux traitements
pour que les patients atteints de cancer
gagnent des mois, voire des années de vie.
La génétique, OK.
Une révolution un peu plus lente
que prévu,
mais qui, avec la démocratisation
des ciseaux à ADN CRISPR-Cas9,
tente aujourd’hui de guérir des maladies
inatteignables jusque-là.
L’intelligence artificielle,
avec des algorithmes
qui sont aujourd’hui capables
de mieux lire certaines radios
ou certains scanners
que les yeux de nos radiologues.
Ou encore les robots
chirurgicaux avec leurs bras articulés
plus minutieux et plus précis que ceux
de nos confrères chirurgiens.
Aujourd’hui, à l’Assistance publique,
c’est 95 % des chirurgies de la prostate
qui sont faites par robots.
Et de plus en plus d’anomalies
ou de tumeurs très complexes à aborder
en chirurgie classique,
elles peuvent l’être
en chirurgie robotique.
Mais dites-moi,
derrière les prescriptions, les bras
des robots, la rédaction des algorithmes,
qui est-ce qui est encore aux manettes ?
C'est bien le chirurgien qui commande
les moindres mouvements du robot.
C’est bien le radiologue qui finalise
le compte rendu d’un examen.
OK, OK, demain,
ce sera peut-être une IA,
mais si c’est le cas,
eh bien en fait, tant mieux.
On n’a pas fait médecine
pour la beauté du diplôme
mais pour que les gens aillent mieux.
Si la tech fait mieux
que moi, je m’incline.
Mais dans la plupart des spécialités,
on en est encore franchement loin.
Palper un ventre, examiner une gorge,
la tech ne sait pas faire.
Et puis non, on ne va pas faire
des scanners du corps entier
chaque fois que quelque chose cloche.
Ces examens sont irradiants et à force,
c’est votre risque de cancer qui augmente.
Communiquer avec empathie,
la tech ne sait pas faire non plus.
Alors oui, vous allez me dire
que beaucoup de médecins
ne savent pas très bien faire non plus.
Et vous avez raison, c’était le point
de mon introduction.
Mais la solution au problème,
ce n’est pas toujours la machine.
La solution ici, c'est de mieux former
les médecins à la communication.
Parce que oui, contre toute attente,
eh bien, ça s’apprend.
C’est encore beaucoup
trop peu enseigné aujourd’hui,
mais c’est un grand axe
en voie de développement.
Ah non, non, non, non, non,
ne me parlez pas non plus
des robots humanoïdes
capables d’analyser
les émotions faciales humaines
et ensuite de mimer
une empathie en retour.
Non, non, une fausse empathie,
ça fascine, mais ça ne fait pas illusion.
On oublie parfois
que lorsque l’on souffre,
lorsque l’on porte le poids
de la maladie sur ses épaules,
eh bien, on a besoin d’informations
qui soient adaptées à notre personnalité,
à notre état d’esprit,
à notre contexte de vie.
On a besoin de se sentir écouté, entendu.
On a même besoin d'affection
et d'espoir en retour.
Alors dans tous ces cas-là,
sans nous remplacer, la tech nous aide.
Elle nous aide à mieux
diagnostiquer, à mieux traiter.
Parfois, elle s’occupe
de tâches techniques
qui permettent de nous rendre du temps
de consultation avec nos patients.
Parfois aussi, elle nous vole
de ce temps de consultation.
Un peu trop, dans une optique
administrative toujours plus compliquée,
mais aussi dans l’intérêt
du patient, de temps en temps.
Au final, le message ici,
c’est que la tech est à notre service,
à nous humains,
mais c’est bien nous
qui la construisons, non ?
Mais c’est à nous de lui dire
ce qu’on veut qu’elle fasse !
La question ne doit pas être
si la tech va nous remplacer.
La question doit être : que veut-on
qu’elle nous aide à accomplir ?
Et aujourd’hui,
elle nous offre de plus en plus
de possibilités.
Alors justement, soigner demain,
qu’est-ce que ça veut dire ?
Si avant d’aller de l’avant,
on retourne encore une fois en arrière.
Avant, c’était assez simple
parce que vous n’aviez pas vraiment
d’outils pour soigner.
Par exemple, avant l’arrivée
de l’échographie,
on ne pouvait rien détecter
chez les fœtus avant la naissance.
Alors les bébés naissaient
et puis on gérait ce qu’on pouvait.
Puis l’échographie obstétricale
est arrivée.
On a pu détecter tout un tas
d’anomalies durant la grossesse
et parfois proposer des solutions,
une chirurgie in utero, par exemple.
Ça me fait penser, au passage,
pour ceux qui pensent que la tech
va remplacer l’humain,
vous remarquerez que l’arrivée
d’une technologie comme l’échographie
n’a sûrement pas privé
les gynécologues de travail.
Bien au contraire,
elle en a donné pléthore.
Enfin, aujourd’hui, grâce à la génétique,
on peut maintenant aller plus loin
que contrôler la bonne santé des fœtus.
On peut tenter de choisir certaines
caractéristiques de l'enfant à naître.
Avec la PMA, en choisissant par exemple
un donneur de sperme blond.
Heu, pff, non, non, plutôt brun.
Heu, un homme ayant fait
de hautes études
et bien sûr, très beau sur la photo.
En Ukraine, moyennant finance,
c’est l’étape d’après,
vous pouvez choisir le sexe
et la couleur des yeux du futur bébé.
Et vous ?
Si vous pouviez choisir votre enfant,
quelles caractéristiques choisiriez-vous ?
Et si, par exemple, votre choix se portait
sur un garçon aux yeux bleus ?
Mais qu’il naissait avec le gros nez
du grand-oncle
ou qui, en grandissant,
s’avérait être un grand criminel.
Assumeriez-vous tout autant ?
Car on peut choisir des choses,
mais quand même,
mais on ne peut pas tout choisir non plus.
Il y a toujours des imprévus.
Ou alors, est-ce que vous laisseriez
la nature faire ?
Ici, bébé 100 % naturel garanti.
C’est stressant d’y réfléchir, non ?
Moi, ça me stresse, en tout cas.
Parce qu’en fait, quand on parle
de technologie pour réparer l’homme,
tout le monde est d’accord sur le sujet.
Mais quand la technologie
nous permet d’aller plus loin,
de ne plus simplement réparer l’homme,
mais de l’augmenter,
alors là, c’est un nouveau
monde qui se profile.
Quand je dis réparer,
c’est ramener le corps humain
à un état de bon fonctionnement.
Par exemple, je suis myope.
Eh bien, on me prescrit des lunettes pour
voir à nouveau bien, normalement.
Je me casse une jambe,
on me met un plâtre
le temps que mon os se répare
pour pouvoir à nouveau
marcher normalement.
Augmenter, c’est donner à l’homme
des capacités supérieures
aux capacités humaines.
Ça peut être, comme on l’a vu
pour des parents,
de choisir tel ou tel embryon à naître.
Mais ça peut aussi être, par exemple, de
s’insérer un implant rétinien dans l’œil
afin de voir la nuit,
ou un implant cochléaire dans l’oreille
afin d’entendre une gamme
de sons plus élargie.
Ça peut être s’habiller d’un exosquelette
pour courir plus vite qu’Usain Bolt,
ou s’implanter une carte électronique
dans le cerveau
pour majorer ses capacités
de mémorisation.
Mais alors, dans ce cas-là,
devient-on un super-humain ?
Ou à l’inverse, devient-on moins humain ?
Une sorte de post-humain, peut-être ?
Ce questionnement m’amène à une question
encore plus fondamentale,
qui est celle de savoir, grâce à la
médecine et à la technologie,
quelle humanité nous voulons
construire pour demain.
Alors, il y en a une qui a quand même
déjà planché sur le sujet,
c’est la science-fiction.
Elle nous a imaginé, par exemple,
un monde basé sur la normopathie.
Ça, c’est le film Minority Report,
avec Tom Cruise.
Tout le monde doit être dans
une norme de bonne santé,
l’anormalité est traquée, punie.
Fini le deuxième croissant
du dimanche matin
et la journée canapé télé sans bouger.
Et puis, merci de sourire au travail,
c’est important pour la productivité
de l’entreprise.
Ah non, pardon de votre productivité
personnelle, excusez-moi.
On a aussi pu avoir des scénarios,
par exemple, transhumanistes,
avec le film Terminator.
Là, c’est la course effrénée
des super-héros, mi-homme, mi-robot
ou ni homme, ni robot.
Ils sont toujours plus forts,
toujours plus intelligents,
mais toujours plus assoiffés de pouvoir,
toujours plus irresponsables et égoïstes.
Et puis, on a pu avoir des scénarios
sur l’eugénisme,
avec le film Bienvenue à Gattaca
avec Uma Thurman.
Là, on choisit simplement
le sexe et la couleur des yeux,
c’est un être sur mesure.
Mais alors, quand on façonne l’être humain
au point de lui retirer toute capacité
à s’auto-déterminer,
quelle liberté lui reste-t-il ?
Et puis, bien sûr, on a eu
les scénarios d’immortalité.
Moi, je me demande :
quand on est immortel, peut-on avoir
éternellement des enfants ?
Parce que ça fait beaucoup
de monde quand même.
Par exemple, limitera-t-on
les parents à un enfant tous les 200 ans ?
Non, non, non, non, non,
tous les 2000 ans.
Et où est-ce qu’on va les mettre ?
Sur Mars ?
Mais vous avez vu tous
les cratères sur Mars ?
Non, parce que, en fait,
sur la Terre, on n’en a pas,
parce qu’on a un truc qui s’appelle
le champ magnétique,
qui fait que le ciel
ne nous tombe pas sur la tête.
Moi, perso, désolé, mais je reste ici.
Un autre exemple :
si on imaginait un monde où,
à force de vouloir remplacer toutes
les compétences humaines possibles
par la technologie,
nous devenions idiots,
totalement asservis et dépendants
d’une technologie,
ne sachant plus rien faire seul,
jusqu’à perdre toute capacité
de réflexion par nous-mêmes.
Et vous, quel est le scénario
que vous redoutez le plus ?
Ou celui que vous voudriez voir
se réaliser ?
OK, ma question peut
vous paraître un bon prétexte
pour aller revisionner les films
que je viens de mentionner
ou un bon starter pour vos conversations
lors de votre prochain dîner entre amis.
Mais probablement une question
un peu lointaine
pour s’en préoccuper sérieusement,
n’est-ce pas ?
Et ce n’est pas moi,
un petit être sur cette grande planète,
qui ai un quelconque pouvoir de décision.
Eh bien, je ne suis pas
tout à fait d’accord.
Parce que si on n’empêche pas l’avenir,
c’est vrai,
on contribue à l’influencer
d’une façon ou d’une autre.
C'est l'effet papillon.
Ma philosophie à moi, c’est que,
dans cette vie, nous avons deux trésors.
La planète
et la santé.
Sans l’un et l’autre, nous n’avons rien.
Alors, si la Terre est notre vaisseau,
comme c'est le thème d'aujourd'hui,
utilisons trois maillons
dont nous disposons :
la nature, l’humanité et la technologie,
afin de garder le cap, de tenir la barre
tous ensemble, collectivement.
Personnellement, je ne suis pas convaincue
par une sorte de transformation
dans un être post-humain.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que, quand on regarde
la technologie,
oui, elle a permis d’immenses progrès
dans de nombreux domaines :
la science, la médecine, le monde
du transport, de l’habitation.
Mais, a-t-elle permis le moindre progrès,
et ce, depuis la nuit des temps,
quant à notre conscience,
à nous, humains ?
Notre pensée, notre éthique,
notre bonheur intérieur.
Est-ce que, si demain nous pouvions
nous reprogrammer sans défaut,
nos conjoints nous aimeraient plus ?
La Terre serait-elle plus paisible si,
par exemple,
nous avions tous des corps parfaits ?
Je pense qu’un des problèmes,
c’est qu’on se focalise trop
sur la technologie
comme l’ultime source de tous
les progrès et toutes les dérives.
Mais, elle n’a jamais été le problème.
Le problème, c’est le singe derrière
les manettes, c’est nous.
C'est ce qu'on choisira
d'en faire ensemble.
Et pour pouvoir continuer à choisir,
à choisir ensemble,
il faut parler de ces sujets,
il faut les enseigner pour nous
et pour les générations à venir
afin de garder ce pouvoir
de réflexion et de décision
et de ne pas simplement le laisser
aux géants du numérique
ou aux politiques.
Mais encore une fois, peut-être qu’avant
de parler de technologie et de médecine,
la première question à évoquer ne
serait-elle pas celle de savoir finalement
ce qui nous rendrait plus heureux
dans nos vies et sur cette Terre,
et de voir si la technologie
est un outil de réponse ou pas.
Et après, on pourra s’aventurer à rêver
d’êtres augmentés par la technologie.
Mais ça, c’est pour une autre histoire
et celle d’aujourd’hui est terminée.
(Applaudissements)